hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to Cave crawler a game where
you're crawling through caves I believe
you're looking for dead bodies or live
bodies I'm not sure which would be
more appropriate in this situation after
acquiring Mining rights to the area 92
Rockwell mining group was all alerted by
local park and Forest services to a
missing person's report near the
entrance to company property the
following footage showcases the use of
the cave crawler a newly patented survey
drone developed by RMG all right sounds
good
find the missing person okay
[Music]
why does it look like teeth is it
supposed to look like teeth
what's behind me
nothing
how do I look up
can I look up
I don't think I'm gonna look up oh I can
look up okay that's where I came from
well seems inaccessible but whatever
that's definitely doofuses
100 toothless so I gotta find the
missing person
why
also I gotta remember I'm just a robot
I'm in no danger
nothing could befall me
I have a fork in the road here
if that's a dead Ender if it goes around
the bend I don't trust that way
and this way looks equally disturbing is
that a foot
boot
another look at this boot do I picture
train
oh oh scanning
zero DNA detected well that's weird or
is it
or maybe it's not
all I know is that it's a boot
huh
did this just loop back around from that
other direction
like it might have
my innate sense of direction is telling
me to go this way
foreign
[Music]
why is everyone with everything sound so
wrong
[Music]
okay
hmm
[Music]
is there something on the ceiling up
there
and this is more tooth
I don't know about that one
[Music]
I don't know about that
what is that it's a backpack what is it
isolated hiker's bag content's unknown
probably because I don't have the
dexterity to open it oh I was gonna
careen off the cliff
hello
[Music]
anybody over there
right okay
well so far so nothing
[Music]
I know I've talked about it before but
still sometimes I just think about that
map
[Music]
the one that overlays like missing
persons reports
and the U.S cave system
and it's just like I know there's
probably some hyperbole in that and I'm
pretty sure
pretty sure it's Tastefully selected
information
but still
it can't be denied that people
tend to die in caves
or mysteriously go missing
and think about those videos of people
who are cave explorers having to push
all the breath out of their lungs just
to cram their bodies through the
tightest Gap you've ever seen in your
life why is there light here
hello
well that was unfortunate for somebody
I just don't understand that I don't
have Supreme claustrophobia but I have a
good sense of survival low battery
charge
yeah handheld light source it's called a
flash
[Music]
I don't need this to get more narrow I
really don't
oh
why am I able to scan this
unauthorized excavation tunnel well I'm
sure that was completely naturally made
and none too much of a concern for me
that's that seems like more
Stalag mites and tights I don't know
which one's which
remember there being am I going in a
circle wait I'm climbing back up
oh
so that did connect up but it just
didn't connect where I thought it
connected up wait let me go back because
I'm pretty sure that there was another
offshoot path that I could have taken
over there
that can't have been the only things
down here
it's like playing Minecraft down here
with all the mysterious cave noises I
don't need any of that in my life
[Music]
I don't even have life I'm a robot
I'm just a drone I still haven't found
the missing person do I have turbo mode
can I kick on the nitrous
it was kind of slow
I don't think that there was anything
over here that I missed but I might as
well backtrack one second everybody I'll
let you know if something spooky happens
in the meantime lexian definitely don't
spook him
that would be against the rules
[Music]
what do you mean
what do you mean motion detected
what do you mean what does 4f mean was
that always there for f
4f
[Music]
okay
these noises starting to mean something
else huh
you know I'm just goofing with me right
there has to be something that I missed
but I've already been down that way
there's no way through these teeth maybe
a back towards the entrance there was
something else
wait no rocks
scary rocks but rocks no it's still a
dead end
since but there's only so many places to
go down here and I can't exactly find a
path down to the other side I must be
missing something I always am but
I definitely must is there really
nothing else over here because it was
like unauthorized tunneling
and yet
nothing
which is strange why would that be
what was tunneling that wait a minute
what wait a minute wait a minute
what
was that always there did I miss that
how would I have missed that I found the
missing person oh
discovery after testing the cave crawler
for approximately four hours it was able
to locate the missing hiker's body in a
cave containing a crystalline structure
after further study RMG discovered the
crystals are a highly dense energy
source rivaling the output of current
day nuclear energy sources that sounds
dangerous
dig it up what's the harm after
discovering a new potential fuel source
rmd required deeper exploration to
locate additional Crystal deposits for
further testing
of course
the following footage was collected by
the cave crawler 22 hours after a major
cave and trapped RMG mining Personnel
within the cave
sure
bet it had nothing to do with those
crystals through that flesh
is that blood
is that blood that slowly oozing between
the Rocks what's back this way
[Music]
Mission finding the bodies incomplete of
course it is was this a code for World
hey buddy
[Music]
I'm just gonna pretend like
that didn't happen because it didn't if
you saw anything you're crazy
I'll come back to you later mysterious
object to my right
I'm gonna try to be procedural about
this
crystals that's always good
valuable
Rockwell mining pool I don't think it is
I don't think at all
[Music]
I gotcha
it's a wheelbarrow
Rockwell excavation container well
that's an awfully play way to word in I
suppose
well that makes it feel good about
itself
hello
Cavern blocked cause unknown I think
it's the rocks
you know if I had to place my finger
upon it I assume then it's rocks hello
I see the thing up on the ledge you know
the thing that's on top of the waterfall
of blood but I'm just going to wait
Ultra safe protective head gear you
didn't wear your headgear
sir and or madam
you forgot to put on your headgear I
found a body
the body too well good for you you
probably can put more use to the body
than me
not going to sweat it
it's all good
[Music]
that's a big cavern
that's cavernous if you will
motion detected
I detected that
I don't think you can get away with that
[Music]
I spy with my little eye hey Rockwell
excavation container
that's fine what's with the oozing
fireflies
oh those are beautiful
oh that was gorgeous
also that if
hey um I'm down here if you could stop
the excavation for a little bit longer
be greatly appreciated
um all right
also that's definitely a code of some
kind in the bottom I don't know what
though
what or why but there is a code forming
down there
hello hi you doing all right
you doing all right pal uh
well
you're undulating beautifully I found a
body
oh boy I sure did
[Music]
okay is this like an autonomous drone or
is this just like
someone piloting this and seeing it and
witnessing it
another cave-in
[Music]
hello oh
is that a body
that do be a body I would have missed
that one you lost your helmet if all how
did you even get down there that doesn't
make any sense oh
harvesting
what after searching for two hours the
cave crawler was only able to locate the
bodies of three of the miners still
intact alongside personal equipment of
the remaining twelve upon further
examinations the recovered bodies
provided important medical data on the
crystalline structures did they that
doesn't seem like the conclusion you
should draw from this action
it seems like something went horribly
horribly wrong
did it give you any clue of the horrible
nightmares that are lurking down in the
deep deep depths
beginning as small spores once contact
has been made with a form of biological
material the crystals will begin to grow
by converting the biological matter into
energy after implantation small
crystalline formations appearing within
24 hours with crystals reaching full
mature maturation after 48 hours
beginning at 0800 hours seismic
detectors register to slow build up of
vibrations deep within the rmd pit after
two localized seismic events contact was
lost with the feeding team
the what team Cape crawler was deployed
to locate the missing team members uh of
the uh team members of of what
organization
um
oh good I was hoping for tentacles
that's what I was thinking that this was
all missing
tentacles and hot dogs that's great you
keep doing that that's that's just
tickling the cloth allows for the bodies
to breathe
uh-huh
uh-huh how about that I have questions
they're still alive
who
who is still alive
bodies ready to be implanted
[Music]
there is no turning back I'm a robot
I don't think I have much agency in this
but at the same time my survival
Instinct programming is really ramping
up
legally mandated biohazard warning good
well all right wearing a mask is highly
recommended but not mandated we are not
responsible for any medical issues RMG
okay well you know how about a whole
lead-lined suit
um
all right I'll go naked I think naked is
the best strategy in the face of
whatever the hell this is
because this is
definitely not a massive creature's
butthole hello
are you part of the feeding team
lovely tentacles the blood fireflies are
great this year the seed is first
planted
that's the conclusion to draw is that my
uh programming leaping to these
conclusions or is this um
there's something else
[Music]
uh-huh that's what I thought
okay
goodbye
[Music]
that's fine
is that a puddle puddle of what Puddle
of what don't say blood don't whoa
you can say blood unknown liquid okay
definitely not blood 100 not blood
absolutely definitely not blood what's
up there hi
you uh implanting up there
a mistake was made
a mistake
no mistake I feel like many mistakes
might have been made to get to this
conclusion where we are right now but
whatever
is what it is
[Music]
I really wish these tentacles would stop
tickling my grundle
oh oh
[Music]
you're right there
you okay
hmm
you found a crystal
uh-huh I sure did
that's what I did
and I'm not gonna go there that seems
like it's going back it's not the same
way I went but it's in the same
direction let me see if I can get across
this Chasm this Chasm of mysterious
unknown liquid
definitely mysterious unknown liquid
uh-huh
oh yeah that's a crystal all right
that's Crystal all right
[Music]
how have I only found one of the team
I feel like
well that's nothing to worry about is
that a team member
of the feeding team
there are no bodies left only the
crystals okay well I'm really not having
a good success rate on finding these
team members
I'm beginning to think that there aren't
going to be any survivors down here
well this looks fun
but apparently there's wait a minute
did I see a Tootsie
Burger all the way around for a good
view this one
I don't know if that's qualifies as a
titsy but I found something
great
so that was two of five
I'm really batting a low average here
I'm not not doing terribly good see you
know I'm I'm down here exploring for the
missing team but honestly I don't even
know
I don't even know how they qualify as
missing I just think that if you go down
here do you really expect to come back
is that like a is that a natural
conclusion here that we need to explore
because it seems just to me that if
there's a feeding team and this thing
turns into biological matter that you
kind of dump them down a hole and then
just
that's it kind of hit
you know I don't I don't know about any
kind of return
oh hey I see you what are you
damn all right
good
great
[Music]
it's kind of a low soon
let's not go back the way I came
slightly different
hard to tell
whoa what in the heck
agitated crystalline object agitated as
in pissed off or stirred
that could be
many definitions there uh also am I I
still don't know if I'm going in a
circle and that was just an event that
happened here
I have a funny feeling I'm going in a
circle
it was a circle
this is
[Music]
so yeah okay let me go back this way
because that was it wasn't quite the
circle where I thought it was so this
area is still unknown
so I still need to explore this section
of it
oh
uh-huh okay black void of nothingness
what is what is going on down there
unknown organic Mass detected
oh good
great
that's good
that's good hello
hi you part of the feeding team
yeah I found a crystal are you sure
that that's the thing I should be
celebrating because it seems like I
should be finding team members and yet
you keep referring to them
he has crystals
you laughing at me why you laughing at
me what do you think so funny you think
there's a joke huh my very serious job
that I take extremely seriously
you think it's funny
this last one
seed begins to sprout so you're telling
me this is not a team member what's your
delineation on what is and is not team
is there a some over there
is that all still the same okay that's
all still the same there's got to be one
more area around here probably towards
the beginning that I missed or
overlooked am I seeing someone over
there no just more tentacles
[Music]
can I scan you already I must have I
must have
[Music]
I did not how did I miss you well I
guess because you look exactly like all
the others so maybe you're the last one
oh great oh good red warning
federal law provides severe civil and
criminal penalties for the unauthorized
reproduction distribution or exhibition
of copyrighted Motion Pictures
videotapes or video discs
that's a weird warning to put here in
this place right now
the following footage is for internal
use only unauthorized use may result in
major fines and or a penalty of up to 65
in prison
internal report uf001 the following
footage was collected from Rockwell
mining Group after the results of Agents
redacted and redacted investigation into
the origin of the earthquake RMG was
immediately subpoenaed for further
documentation regarding records of the
mining site
uh-huh upon review the following footage
is believed to be what caused the
disaster
uh-huh
oh oh once more under the breach
ah good I seem to have poop on my lens
[Music]
okay okay
you know um
caves don't look so good
[Music]
ow my eyes
whoa
whoa cool
unknown organic map cool
very cool
very cool I mean probably horrific and
world ending but still pretty cool I
don't mind it
it's not too bad
cool
big Crystal
multiple bodies detected I'm sure I'm
sure
sure yeah I'm sure okay
that's a little goopier than it needs to
be
that's the little more penisy than it
needs to be
well maybe not
[Music]
undulating intestinal tract ah okay
clearly not penile in any way I see I
see
he's given big mystery flesh pit vibes
how you been
ah everyone loves Carlos life of the
party that guy
just uh you take it easy Carlos you have
a good one
you have it all right okay okay all
right love that guy
[Music]
still really goopy
and who's it gonna be
William F wow in the flash so to speak
Mario L yep
oh down oh God
all right well we're just going for it I
don't like the way it moves
[Music]
oh oh
okay
this is fine
so good
what is that you've got a some dirt on
your
okay
oh well my mistake okay
my bad
internal report conclusion upon further
investigation of the provided materials
and under the order of the current
director of Homeland Security RMG has
been contracted to continue study of the
caves under the direct supervision of
doctor redacted
really that makes perfect sense
definitely trust them
ah Mario L William F I didn't find
Gabriel well where's Carlos
oh
that's big that's big
please rewind the tip before returning
into filing Personnel I think I have a
horror game in my queue called rewind or
die so maybe that'll be next just
because thematically it makes sense what
following the conclusion of internal
internal internal report uf001 reports
of similar geological incidents have
been received from monitoring stations
indicating events at there there
redacted there there and there
as instructed by doctor redacted and Dr
montow survey Crews have been dispatched
to all locations for further local
investigation
good ah there's more well that was
pretty fun I like that it was a little
simplistic it was a little slow it
didn't have nearly as much uh
horrific Ambiance as I was expecting it
to have although it was like a darker
tone in it the exploration is fun it was
just a little slow it's times but still
I like what they're trying to do the
whole world building flesh pit of
nightmares I'm a sucker for that kind of
stuff so very good
and I hope you enjoyed it thank you
everybody so much for watching you can
play this link this you could play this
game through the link in the description
you can play this game for yourself
through the link in the description
below and check out more scary games
that I've played down there as well
thank you and as always I will see you
in the next
bye-bye
foreign
[Music]